aunque la apuesta es reducir las
emisiones de carbono el mundo va por el
camino contrario porque esas emisiones
se están aumentando y a niveles
catastróficos el nuevo reporte de la
organización meteorológica mundial de la
onu estima que como van las cosas el
mundo se podría calentar 27 grados
celsius para finales de este siglo un
nivel muy por encima del límite de 2
grados que se pactó en el acuerdo de
parís
a menos que las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero se reduzcan de manera
inmediata rápida y a gran escala no
seremos capaces de limitar el
calentamiento global a 1,5 grados
celsius y las consecuencias serán
catastróficas y catastrófico
para entender los impactos es solo mirar
lo que está pasando los desastres
naturales han incrementado tanto por el
calentamiento global y el cambio
climático que mientras unos países
sufren por inundaciones repentinas otros
enfrentan incendios forestales más
devoradores que antes actualmente el
mundo está entre 106 grados celsius y
1,26 grados celsius más caliente que en
las épocas pre industriales lo que es
mucho menos de la mitad de la
temperatura que habría para finales de
siglo según el reporte
a pesar de que el calentamiento global
va en aumento menos de la mitad de los
países han presentado apuestas más
ambiciosas para reducir las emisiones
que es lo que se discutirá en la cob 26
de glasgow en noviembre y con los
compromisos actuales las emisiones
globales serían 16 por ciento más altas
en 2030 en vez de reducir las un 45%
como se esperaba
como ya dije una de las cuellos de
botella de la cob 26 será cuán
preparados estamos para empezar a actuar
ya durante esta década esta táctica o
reading list y kate y mientras países
como china e india siguen sin trazar sus
nuevos compromisos a pesar de ser dos de
las tres naciones más contaminantes
otros como brasil y méxico presentaron
metas que reducen sus ambiciones
climáticas